here's a theory Game of Thrones is
really all about climate climate change
climate change we are hurtling toward
the day when climate change could be
irreversible really why it's so bad
and why it's so hard to do anything
about it think about the White Walkers
those horrifying monsters with the
zombie army that killed everyone in that
crazy battle at hardhome they're an
inhuman destructive force that literally
changes the weather during their
onslaught like climate change the White
Walkers are a threat to the whole human
race noble houses like the Stars the
Lannisters the Baratheon's Martel's and
the Bolton's are too busy fighting with
each other over control of the kingdom
to come together over a common threat
sometimes they even deny that White
Walkers are real I don't believe that
Giants and ghouls and White Walkers are
lurking beyond the wall you've probably
seen charts of co2 emissions
skyrocketing in the 20th and 21st
century as humans industrialized and
you've probably also seen charts that
show just how bad that's going to be if
we don't stop it rising flood levels
droughts ocean acidification climate
changes this massive global threat but
stopping it requires the world's biggest
nations like China India and the u.s. to
sacrifice a little in the short term and
put away their political competition
with each other in the meantime the
world's poorest people the wildlings in
the show suffer and the experts in the
real world or our own Night's Watch
stands on the sidelines that's why
Charlie carpenter political scientists
at the University of Massachusetts calls
Game of Thrones a collective action
story the story of the northern wall and
the force it holds at bay she says is
about the mistaken belief that the
industrial civilization can stand
against the changing forces of nature
people love yelling at the characters on
the show for ignoring the zombie threat
in the north but if our zombies are
climate change and we are not doing
nearly enough to prevent catastrophic
global warming who should you really be
annoyed with
[Music]
[Music]